this question might not apply to you i
asked this of all filmmakers but i would
imagine a lot of people want to be in
business with you but maybe um if you
get the financing for any project you
want to make what would you make and why
ah
um
i've been really lucky in my career and
then i've gotten to make a lot of the
movies that were in my heart
and i don't think i want to spoil the
ones i'm thinking of making
um
i don't know
i mean
like you know people really hated on gus
von sant when he remade psycho
but i understand that i understand the
desire
to know what it feels like to set up
those shots and just to know what it
feels like to make that movie it's very
selfish and very personal but there's
all kinds of movies that i love that i
would want to know just what it feels
like to actually make them
no matter the outcome so if i could just
go
make a shot for shot remake of ferris
bueller just to know what it felt like i
think that would be a lot of fun but it
would be a completely selfish endeavor
and i admit going in that it would never
be as good as the original
okay if someone has never seen anything
that you've directed what do you want
them to start with and why
oh uh
if someone was going to watch one film
of mine i suppose i'd want them to watch
young adult there's a course truth to
that film that i really believe in
i think it's a film that i kind of made
at my bravest
same same question but about your dad's
movies
i mean if you're going to watch one
movie of my father's
i think you guys either got to watch
dave or you got to watch ghostbusters
you know uh ghostbusters is absolutely
iconic it's a perfect film
but the storytelling level on dave is
off the charts
and
from a filmmaking point of view i think
it's my favorite of my father's films
i i love dave davis is fantastic um
which of your films changed the most in
the editing room in a way that you
weren't expecting
i don't know
probably thank you for smoking because i
was it was my first movie i had the
least amount of experience
it has the most deleted scenes
i was still figuring it out i mean i'm
still figuring it out now but on thank
you for smoking
i had made short films i had made
commercials
but
i was still learning how to make a movie
and so there were the most mistakes and
there was the you know i probably had to
reorder the most and cut the most
uh what would you want to see in a
ghostbusters ride if you had the control
to
sort of dictate the way it went oh my
god like like a look at a theme park
yeah
amazing question all right so
the
the chase sequence
in ghostbusters afterlife with phoebe
hanging out the side of ecto-1 flying
around corners trying to catch muncher i
mean that is something i want to live i
want to know what it feels like to hang
out the side of the car i made it
because
you know i'm trying to relive fantasies
of riding in the delorean or riding on
speeder bikes on endor and returning the
jedi so
if i could know what it felt like you
know there's that great uh
ride at disney no at universal orlando
it's a
hogwarts ride where
you're on uh hagrid's uh
a motorbike with the sidecar
and if we could do something like that
with ecto-1
so down
okay i'm thinking about this and i
actually yeah i would love to have the
proton pack and
do everything that she does that would
be fantastic um so jumping back i am
curious uh when did you actually realize
that you really did want to make a
ghostbusters movie like what was that
moment you know what i mean that hit you
you know it's a combination of moments
is the truth i uh obviously had been
asked my whole life you know uh would i
ever make a ghostbusters movie
and i think i always thought that people
wanted to see my ghostbusters movie but
maybe that was just my ego talking you
know what people really wanted was just
a ghostbusters movie they wanted to see
someone pick up the proton pack again
they wanted to see ecto-1 fly around the
corner again they want to see those guys
standing next to each other again
and it it came to me through this girl
you know i imagined this 12 year old
girl
standing in a field with a proton pack
and
it was only later that i realized that
this was egon spengler's granddaughter
and once i knew who she was that journey
started to build in my mind and i
pitched it to my father and he loved it
and
it was i think probably watching my
father's reaction as he heard the story
that made me want to tell it
how did you end up connecting with gil
to write the screenplay well gil ken and
i met playing hockey together 15 years
ago if you can imagine and uh we fast
became very good friends our daughters
are the same age we began writing
together we wrote a movie for dreamworks
animation together and we adapted a book
for amazon together so we already had
experience working together and really
trusted each other's brains
and i was pitching him my thoughts on a
ghostbusters movie and he really
responded to them he started to go back
and forth on it and he's part of the
reason i got the confidence to actually
tell the story
uh there's always obviously other ideas
that almost made it in the script were
there were there any like big things
that you ended up coming up with that
you're like oh this is great but yeah we
can't use this
yeah
tons of ideas and i'm not going to tell
you them because i'm hoping to save them
for other movies but look uh
when we started making a script for
ghostbusters afterlife it was originally
called rust city
we
we had all kinds of ideas we wanted to
get in there we were making lists of
anything we'd ever want to see in a
ghostbusters movie
uh and one of them was a car chase a car
chase with someone hanging out the side
with a proton pack and other ideas were
unmakeable at this point but hopefully
in the future
um you mentioned rust city uh was so
basically it was originally ghostbusters
rust city then it became afterlife like
what was was it ever another title no
russ city was kind of our code name we
knew that these projects required code
names we were writing it in secrecy we
knew we needed some other name um and
rust city of course came uh from the
selenium mine you know this is a movie
that you know really is uh
the you know comes out of the the
foundry and selenium mine that led to
the building of dana's apartment
building in 1984.
yeah i do like that connective tissue um
but so but i am curious was it ever
another name but ghostbusters afterlife
that you really considered or once you
got that name that that was it no once
we got that name that was it i mean you
know in moving off of russ city we had
to come up with a real name for it and
we did toss around some ideas but
uh afterlife quickly led to the top
uh you've worked with your uh dp eric
for on many movies uh how did you guys
this how did you come up with the look
that you wanted for this film you know
with the i'm guessing you could just
talk about working with eric and how you
decided on that certainly i mean look
eric and i met when we were teenagers we
worked with each other forever uh we
have just a common language at this
point in approaching ghostbusters
afterlife
we wanted something that not only echoed
ghostbusters and you know the stunning
cinematography of laszlo kovacs but
really the look of films that we grew up
with so we're talking about the amblin
films of the 80s and this is the movies
that eric and i watched when we were uh
you know 10 11 12 years old talking
about
e.t talking about gremlins talking about
back to the future you know uh
and
there's a warmth and a nostalgic to
those films
that
makes you feel like you lived them even
if you had not and
that's the look we wanted ghostbusters
afterlife to have
um you have uh
one of these things that you had to do
you and gil with the screenplay is you
had to thread that needle of making the
movie work for people that have never
seen ghostbusters and you need to also
make it uh work for the people like me
who grew up on ghostbusters right um at
what point did you like
possibly rage quit and say this is
[ __ ] impossible you know i'm joking
but it's like you managed to do it but
it's a really hard task it's very kind
of you and uh
and certainly we felt like we wanted to
make a movie for everybody we want to
make a movie that was there whether it
was the hundredth time you were seeing a
ghostbusters movie or if this was the
first ghostbusters movie you ever saw we
wanted this experience to work for you
and that included
embracing everything about the original
recipe the car the pack the music the
sound effects uh the guys uh but it also
included introducing a new family in a
new location on a family journey instead
of one of opening up a business
uh it was a tricky thing to weave
because you're right there's ghostbuster
fans who are checking the boxes to make
sure you hit everything and there's
people who want a completely new
experience to this who want to meet new
people
uh 100 percent i love the some people
the many state puffs obviously i had a
blast with and i love how brutal you are
with them in the movie and i'm just
curious did anyone ever say to you okay
i think you're killing them a little too
hard in this
ah
no no i mean uh
god knows i had much more demonic ideas
for these little guys than we got to put
on screen i mean if i could make the
r-rated version of the mini puffs i
think uh it would be a delight for me
and maybe a few others
but
honestly
sony was so supportive of the film we
wanted to make they they really got what
we were trying to do here and
we felt an incredible amount of freedom
to explore what a ghostbusters movie was
what the taxonomy of the ghosts were how
to recreate things like the pterodacts
and it was a thrill to work with this
group of 100
artisans and craftspeople and actors who
all love the original and just wanted to
know what it felt like to be inside a
ghostbusters movie
yeah i believe you had you had a
practical um
uh like a of the dog like uh you had
these big practical puppets if you will
or
i don't i'm using the wrong terminology
no animatronics yeah yeah so um i'm just
curious um who has them and what do i
need to do to get one yeah well so the
thing with these uh uh
uh the thing with these prosthetics is
that
the uh the structures inside them are
very robust but of course the skin is
made out of latex uh and it
disintegrates so uh i'm not sure if
you'll be able to get a hold of any of
them i'm sure that aryan the creator who
of course did pans labyrinth and many
other films uh he probably has one
somewhere in you know cold storage yeah
i'm totally joking right now obviously
but you know i think would be awesome
outside my front door just i know you're
looking for where you need to break into
steal one of these things 100
um
no matter how much money you have no
matter how long your schedule there's
always going to be things that sort of
can't get done i'm just curious what
were some of the big obstacles he faced
in trying to
make this movie
with uh with you know the budget and
time you had
yeah i mean look i think there is a way
that people have gotten used to making
movies these days and that is on green
screen with uh only computer effects and
we wanted to make a movie that balanced
the leading edge of technology with real
old-school hollywood filmmaking so it
meant building sets building complete
sets like the you know like the temple
and the big farmhouse so that set pieces
happen with actors inside them who were
integrated into the actual environments
in real life it meant using old school
effects that maybe some people had to
relearn how to use old wire stuff smoke
stuff using dry ice using mirrors using
magnets uh
and the fun thing is that all these
technicians the reason i went into
filmmaking is because they love this old
stuff they used to read sinifex magazine
you know
they want to actually pull all this
stuff off so
it became this fun challenge of how can
you do this the way they did it back in
84.
uh guillermo is famous for always when
he's
building stuff for his movies to always
build an extra one for his collection
and i'm just curious about the houses
oh
i've seen it firsthand and it's amazing
uh but i'm just curious if you um built
any uh proton packs or anything for this
movie that you said let's just build one
more because i need it at my house
uh
we didn't have the budget for that
but also
oh do you have a bracket
wait what i am a good pickpocket right
now
i thought you were going to pull out
like the ghost trap right there and be
like oh no
so basically you're saying you might
have borrowed some stuff from seth
i'm not understand that you're saying
that i i understand and uh you should
definitely tweet some photos uh just so
we can all see them um uh so one of the
things you have you worked with two
editors on this yeah um and i'm just
curious um nathan and dana and i'm just
curious why two editors and did someone
work on one thing could you explain
absolutely look this is a bigger movie
than i've ever made and it involved a
combination of just
humor thrills scare
there's a car chase in it i mean it was
a whole mix of things and some of which
i'd never done before and i got to work
with two editors that i absolutely love
dana globberman who i've been working
with ever since thank you for smoking
who i knew because she was actually an
assistant in my father's editorial back
uh in the day
and uh nate orlov who gonna join me on
front runner and on tully uh who cut one
of my favorite
ex
you know sequences in tully the uh the
montage of the first six months
in a child's life
and um
[Music]
and together they made the perfect
editing team they they split up all the
work evenly uh there was always this
kind of give or take about who would be
right for the right sequence then they
would pass it back to each other and i
loved it i i hope i get to work with
both of them again exactly the same way
i always ask this to filmmakers i think
i've probably asked it of you in the
past uh how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film oh my god
uh the first cut was easily over three
hours and now we're down to i think an
hour 56 with credit so
uh it's it's way more slim
do you mean when you say that number you
mean that that's like the assembly cut
yeah that's the assembly cut what was
your what was your cut that you were
like oh this is really good i don't know
how we're going to get it shorter
i don't think i ever feel that way i
mean even a month ago we showed the
movie at cinemacon and my father leaned
over to me at one point during the
screening and i thought he was going to
tell me how proud of me he was and
instead he gave me a note uh and we
opened up the film a week later and like
took another few seconds out of the film
so uh we are always making little tweaks
but i i promise now it is done done
so
the recent trailer that you released has
a few shots that are not in the finished
film yeah uh and so i'm just curious how
many deleted scenes did you actually end
up with
you know i feel like there's more
deleted moments than deleted scenes
there are a few deleted scenes and you
can look forward to seeing them on
however you watch movies at home
is it we're talking a rightman cut or
we're just talking about deleted scenes
no this is the rightman cut you know i
uh i know that directors uh
have a tendency to do those longer
directors cuts but i always prefer the
original film i think there's usually a
reason where you got to where you did
except for certain specific cases
i am proud of the released version of
each one of my movies and
if anything i would always just make
them shorter
finn told me earlier that there was a
oner that you shot of him uh going out
that actually isn't in the movie or
unless i'm mistaken am i wrong about
this
oh yeah
yeah there was this really delightful
one or that uh over at spinners that
started with him cleaning up the place
and followed him running out the door
and jumping into a truck that was barely
coming to a stop and it was fun i mean
obviously on set there's nothing more
joyful than working on a complicated one
or uh front runner was my most thrilling
experience with that uh and uh i'm sure
it always upsets the actor after after
work on all that choreography
no he actually he loved the cut um he
was just like no but there was a great
shot that we did that i loved just
didn't make you know what i mean well
finn is a budding filmmaker so
uh he you know he's writing screenplays
he's directing short films and uh it was
it was awesome just to talk with finn
about
directing and the kind of stuff he's
gonna make one day uh oh final question
do you
um no no not the whole interview just of
the deleted scenes sorry i should be
specific do you think it's like five to
ten minutes of stuff that you're putting
on the blu-ray do you actually know i
don't know
okay i'll you know just i'll leave it
there so you mentioned easter eggs i've
noticed a few of them when i was
watching it are there any really hard to
find easter eggs in the movie that you
want to give fans a hint
i mean there are easter eggs so hard to
find that i don't even know they're in
there yet you got to remember i wasn't
the only one putting them in there we
got set deck we got prop makers we got
visual effects artists everyone was
putting in the tiniest details it begins
with literally
the opening logo of the film where will
files the sound designer is already
placing sounds actual sound files he
pulled from 1984 to put into this movie
we're talking about uh pieces of music
on martin oh the instrument that sounds
like a theremin in the original score
that were placed into the uh you know
opening shot um
if you're looking for the hard to find
ones
one of my favorite lines the original
film is egon saying
uh
as a child i had half a slinky and i
straightened it
so there is a straightened slinky
somewhere in the movie
uh the ghost sniffer that venkman uses
when he goes to dana's apartment in the
original film that can be spotted in the
background somewhere
uh egon's updated pke meter from
ghostbusters 2 also could be spotted
somewhere in the film uh the
housekeeping tag from venkman's office
at columbia university can be spotted
somewhere in the film but i mean if you
start getting down to it there is an
incredible level of uh detail just like
really buried in the background
uh the film has post-credit scenes this
is where we're getting into the more
spoilery stuff that i would
later so i'm curious did you know that
it was going to be those two post-credit
scenes
early on or how did you decide on this
uh i don't want to talk about the
post-credit scenes yet
okay moving on to the next thing uh so
i'm wondering what i can okay so i'll
ask you this
you rapped on this a while ago what have
you when did you actually
when did you actually rap on the movie
rap shooting yeah like you've been i
guess let me say it like this did you
have a good enough time making this film
that if it is a huge hit and sony called
you and said do you have another idea
that you would want to do a sequel
because
i'm just curious like you ha i have to
ask those questions because there's
going to be fans who are going to watch
this and love it and then hope that
you're gonna maybe want to do another
i mean this is what i'll say is
the intent of ghostbusters afterlife
is to set the table for more
ghostbusters movies
you know uh i love the ghostbusters
mythology i know a lot of filmmakers do
i'd love to see more films from other
filmmakers in this universe uh every
culture has their own relationship with
ghosts
and i want to see all of those movies
so could you could see yourself
essentially becoming a steward of the
franchise hoping to get other filmmakers
to have a take on it
you know really what i wanted to do with
this film was create that platform
create that opening
and i have to kind of tip my hat to paul
feig because he's the one who really
broke the doors down he's the one who
said a ghostbusters movie could be
something different than the original
two and i'm standing on his shoulders he
created the runway so that i could make
this film and hopefully i'm creating the
runway so others can make more
yeah i like what paul did with the
material i liked what you did with the
material i think that it's just a ripe
universe um i'm going to say this in a
careful way hopefully you will answer
the ending of this movie yeah has a set
up for a possibility of something do you
know
do you have an answer to that or when
you include something like that do you
um sort of say we'll figure it out later
i have an answer
i'm trying to ask in a way that you know
what i mean that you'll um yeah uh you
know what i mean um [ __ ] man so let me
ask i'll save the other spoiler
questions for later because i really do
want to ask you about
the
third the ending of
cgi and whatnot you know what i'm
talking about i'll say this and here's
an answer i'm comfortable giving and
this is an answer you can use now and
don't need to wait
um ghostbusters afterlife is obviously a
balance of bleeding edge technology and
old techniques that go back to the
beginning of hollywood and the end of
the movie required
the most talented visual effects artists
working at the limits of their ability
that this movie for it to work ends on
something that is different than how a
normal big tentpole movie ends
um
and
i was nervous from day one of whether or
not we were gonna be able to pull it off
and it required brilliant artists much
more talented and intelligent than
myself to do it and
uh
the fact that the end of the movie works
stands on their shoulders
the ending of the movie is fantastic and
i will call i really that's one of the
things i wanted to talk to you about is
the the the blending of that vfx of what
you did and i'm just curious at what
point did you actually realize this will
work because if it doesn't work it the
whole thing is it's going to be an issue
very late in the process
oh really
yes
god i've heard i've spoken to other
filmmakers and they've said that i think
even james gunn said on the suicide
squad with king shark that they had a
version and that at the very almost at
the end he's like this is not working we
need to do it a completely different way
yeah i won't say that it's not as though
it wasn't working and then it was
i will say that it was a very gradual
process uh and i and i can't go more
into it without
giving away too much
but it is a gradual process that took
two years
and uh
uh
and
and for me the results are magical
do you know i uh do you know what you're
gonna do next have you been writing
uh
i have been
writing wood
but i don't know what will be next
is it one of these things where you're
working on like multiple screenplays to
see
what's going to be the one or do you
tend to write one thing at a time you
know i have a tendency to write one
thing at a time i'm really fortunate in
that in the last two years you know i
have found gil kennen as a writing
partner and we write a lot together now
and we work on
you know uh things intended for either
of us to direct he's also obviously a
prominent filmmaker and
um
and we're always kicking the tires on
ideas
i'm talking to gil tomorrow about this
movie is there anything i should ask him
specifically that maybe he won't be
expecting or a fun story that he might
want to talk about i mean you know he
brought this up uh last night at comic
con but you know when gil arrived in
america at the age of seven the first
film he ever saw in a theater was
ghostbusters and the fact that that kind
of kicked off his fascination with
movies and eventually he became the
co-writer of this film is such a
wonderful life arc
um
ask him whatever you want he's such an
articulate filmmaker and uh you know
he's an animator
um you know his career started with
working with spielberg and zemeckis
which is just
insane
um
i don't know ask him what position he
plays in hockey
i've spoken to guild before but i didn't
know about the hockey thing um i have to
stop here but
right uh but in all seriousness though
at some point in the future when you are
comfortable about talking specifics i
would really love to talk specifics
about um stuff if you know what i mean
yeah absolutely um and uh there's a
whole fun story to it yeah but listen
congrats on the movie man and um
i really do hope it's a huge hit
sincerely thank you very much nope cool
i gotta go um have a great day bye